I try to make it seem like I'm just
getting this out but I know all the
moves I know every little piece of it is
just here just go here this is what a
Louie CK joke looks like it's a short
one only 207 words but they're 207 words
that are chosen very purposefully
practiced until every one counts for
something today I want to go through
this joke beat by beat and explore how
louis c.k constructs and performs his
comedy my girls are six and nine now
they're actually a really exciting age
because they're learning to do some cool
stuff
I play fit nicely with my kids that's
really fun every joke has to have a
premise an idea that the inevitable
punch line will snap comedic ly into
place the premise should be really clear
whether it's implied as in some
one-liners or stated outright as Chris
Rock once said a lot of comedians have
great jokes and they don't like why
isn't this working it's not working
because the audience does not understand
the premise in this case the premise has
two parts accomplished in two senses
first Louie is playing Monopoly with his
daughters and second my nine-year-old he
can totally do monopoly this is year old
actually totally get how the game works
but she's not emotionally developed
enough to handle her inevitable law in
every game of Monopoly the second part
of this premise is beautifully
structured because besides very lucidly
delivering the premise that this joke is
going to be how a six-year-old girl
learns what it means to lose in monopoly
we actually get some laughs out of the
sentence by the addition of a couple
words and a strategic rhythm I mean the
simplest way to end the sentence is to
say that she's not emotionally developed
enough to handle losing at monopoly but
instead he says to handle her inevitable
loss
in every game of Monopoly in this way
Louie adds two little comedic surprises
in the premise and make sure to include
a pause so that each can be appreciated
in their own beat you handled her
inevitable loss in every game of
Monopoly because the monopoly laws is
dark it is heavy comedians like Louie CK
are experienced enough to master not
only their own delivery but where the
laughs will occur and their jokes and
how to deal with them telling a joke is
like riding a wave of feeling and if you
watch Louie CK's comedy you'll see that
during last what he does is emphasize
his last line it doesn't give the
audience new information he augments the
information just given something that he
actually learned how to do brilliantly
from Jerry Seinfeld I'm opening for
Jerry and for like twelve hundred or
twenty twenty five hundred people and
people are applauding bits and I had
never encountered that I didn't know how
to handle it I asked Jerry what to do
and he said you stay in the bit you stay
in the bit they're reacting to if you're
angry and that's why they're applauding
you stay in that energy because the
monopoly laws indoors is heavy
nothing when you move it you know
Candyland
oh you got stuck in the [ __ ] middle
baby oh well hurry Megami for lyon you
didn't get to win the choice of
Candyland here though Louie axis if it
was pulled out of thin air is the
perfect counterpoint to monopoly it's
visual the game pops straight into your
mind is an object of colourful innocence
the dramatization and the funny voices
also performed like it was spontaneously
made up but the words and the images he
uses like fudgy thing and gummy tore
Leo's are carefully chosen to enhance
that visual sense Louie is never not in
control and that's important because
since the premise has been so strongly
set up and the counterpoint drawn out so
vividly the laughs that Louis gets here
are actually laughs in anticipation of a
punchline not yet said the audience is
already imagining how dark the Monopoly
lost is going to be just watch how he
gradually increases these anticipatory
laughs like the audience is a fiddle to
the final three word punchlines but when
he loses the monopoly I got a look at
her little face Michael okay here's
what's gonna happen now all your
property everything you have all in
railroad your houses all your money
that's mine man gotta give it all of me
give it that's right one thing Louie
doesn't get recognized for enough in my
opinion is his ability to dramatize in
his jokes when he acts out this
conversation with his daughter the light
touchy kids especially with that hand
movement right on the punch line really
locks the audience into the space where
he wants them to be the audience needs
to see this situation from a
six-year-old perspective for it to work
and if he succeeded the tags or the two
additional punchlines that follow will
be that much more devastating and
hilarious and no no you can't play
anymore see because even though you're
giving me all of that it doesn't even
touch how much
Yomi doesn't even touch a baby you're
going down are is really bad casting the
audience in the perspective of a
six-year-old is important for another
reason because I think on a deeper level
Louie is actually trying to make a
comment here on the actual ruthlessness
of the economy we live in where property
really is taken away from people
sometimes by monopolistic interests with
debt to spare that's the thing whose
daughter is not emotionally developed
enough to comprehend and when we see it
through her eyes the reality seems even
darker than it usually does especially
in the final tech all you've been
working for all day I'm going to take it
now and I'm going to use it to destroy
your sister I mean I'm going to ruin her
it just mayhem on this board for her now
you know more than anything else I think
I'm obsessed with articulation with the
magic of putting things just the right
way
there are 207 words in this joke and not
a single one is wasted they're used
either in meaning or in rhythm to
contribute to the overall effect in
effect that lets us see the world from a
different angle and more importantly
makes us laugh like great poetry great
stand-up comedy is language distilled to
its most potent form and these days
few people distill it better than louis
c.k
[Music]
hey everybody thanks for watching and
thank you to the great courses plus for
sponsoring this episode if you love
learning which I do obviously great
courses plus is a subscription on-demand
video learning service which essentially
means that it's got great college-level
lecture series online about 7,000
subjects literature math science how to
be a better photographer whatever from
some great Ivy League inning university
professors I'm learning something right
now about how great science fiction
works because if there's a Horsley
science fiction I'm going directly for
it if you go to the great courses plus
calm slash nerdwriter there's a link in
the description for that you need a
three month $14.99 per month after that
it's just a great service if you sort of
take some cool lecture series thank you
so much for that also nerdwriter t-shirt
finally I figure these out I really
wanted to get the right color in the
right feel so you would want to actually
wear them outside and inside and dftba
figures out and the best way you can go
there and buy one of these thank you
guys so much for watching I'll see all
of you next Wednesday I did